the magazine has come to where we now
have a sign on the outside of our
building that you can see from the 405
freeway it's a big moment it's a big
moment that we're all very excited about
we looked at this building a few months
ago and said this looks like a ship a
christening ceremony would be a good
thing and so here we are
the greatest progress for liberty
involved i think the evolution the
development the evolution of the
libertarian think tanks reason kato and
other groups that share our vision is to
for justice as litigating the cords
seeing the collapse of communism when i
was in high school it was a source of
pride and it gave me such a sense of
political optimism probably the internet
it's very difficult for government to
control the fall of the soviet union the
liberalisation although hardly freedom
in china I mean just in terms of sheer
numbers of people affected in American
culture the advent and the popularity of
hip hop has broken open the ideas of
many people the ideas about what we can
do with our bodies and our minds
our consumer choices are making us more
free than ever there are always young
people who are rediscovering the
foundations of Liberty from which young
can derive one's rights and the
ingredients of a just Constitution I
think that's a big move forward seems
like you know the walls are really
closing in around those who are still
somewhat bigoted when it comes to
same-sex marriage hopefully people will
be getting smarter and the truth will
come out more easily because of the fact
that it's easier to find it on the
internet
I am a fan of Reason magazine because to
me it is the last place in American
culture where we can find radical ideas
it's that combination of a serious
understanding of ideas with the ability
to communicate and popularize it
insisted that the free society is a
product of reason not a faith not of
trust not of cronyism but because it
makes the best sense for human beings to
live in recent doesn't really add to the
conversation reason creates the
conversation and we're so lucky to work
around a group of people who are smart
and you know by and large non-judgmental
and so keyed into so many facets of
society whether its political or
cultural irrespective of whether it's
cool or in or whether it's cutting-edge
reason has always been that voice a
consistent voice for freedom and liberty
and we are always from the beginning
have had practical hard-hitting
approaches to resolve complex problems
that take Liberty seriously
bye